[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال يحيى ابو الهمام الملقب بامير الصحراء
في تنظيم القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي
ان الفصائل المسلحه في مالي ستنسق جهودها
لاعلان اماره موحده تتصدى لما سماها
الهجمه الصليبيه في اشاره الى القوات
الفرنسيه والافريقيه التي تواصل تقدمها في
وسط وشمال
مالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر ناقشه في عنوانين رئيسيين ما مدى
قدره تنظيم القاعده على تنفيذ تهديداته
تلك والى اي حد جاءت مفاجئه لماكو وباريس
وما المطلوب لمواجهه هذه التهديدات
تجنب تاثيراتها على استقرار مالي وجوارها
[موسيقى]
الاقليمي السهوله التي ترك بها مقاتل
الجماعات الاسلاميه مواقعهم في وسط وشمال
مالي كانت بنظر الكثيرين مؤشرا واضحا على
ان هذه الجماعات تخطط لمعركه اخرى غير تلك
التي ارادتها القوات الحكوميه وحلفاؤها
الفرنسيون والان والقوات المتقدمه تدق
ابواب جو مع قيل الاسلاميين القوي كشف
تنظيم القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي
عما يقول انها خطته للتعامل مع هذه القوات
التي اكد ان انتصاراتها السهله كانت امرا
محسوبا سيكون له بما
بعده يتقدم الفرنسيون الى شمال مالي تصل
قواتهم الى جاو التي تعتبر واحده من اهم
معاقل للاسلاميين المسلحين منذ عام مطار
البلده اصبح في قبضتهم وعلى الارض يختفي
المسلحون بعدما وصفت بمنو شات معهم
اختلطوا بالسكان وذابوا حيث لازي يميزهم
ولا خطوط واضحه لتقدمهم او انسحابهم قبل
جاو في ديبالي ونونو وهبي او هنا في كونا
تبقى الصور شاهدا على طبيعه ما دار من
اشتباكات ثقوب في المباني لا في القلوب
لكن لا صور للعمليات العسكريه نفسها ولا
صور ايضا لقتلى من هذا الجانب او ذاك
وحدها صور كهذه تقول ان ثمه جرحى في صفوف
القوات الماليه الحكوميه وان تكاليف
العمليه العسكريه قد تكون باهضه وذات
تداعيات ارتداد تتجاوز مسرحها الحالي حسب
عسكريين فرنسيين في الميدان فان المسلحين
يستهدفون وقواعدهم وعرباتهم ومخازن
اسلحتهم من الجو فيتراجع قبل ان يختفوا
لاحقا مردت ذلك براي هؤلاء قد قد يكون
اعتماد المقاتلين استراتيجيه الكر والفر
حيث تتراجع اهميه الاحتفاظ بالارض في
مفهوم حرب العصابات لصالح تكبيد العدو
خسائر بشريه فادحه تجعل تقدمه على الارض
عبءا يوجب الانسحاب لاحقا استراتيجيتنا في
المرحله القادمه فنحن والحمد لله خبرنا
جيدا حرب
العصابات و ليس من
استراتيجيتنا المكوث في المدن
[موسيقى]
افغانستان اخرى لكن للفرنسيين ومو لهم هذه
المره هذا ما يتوعد به الرجل وهو ما توقعه
ضمنا احد اكبر قضاه التحقيق في مكافحه
الارهاب في فرنسا فالمسح كما يرى يعتبرون
الفرنسيين الان عدوهم المعلن رقم واحد
ورغم السهوله الواضحه التي اخلى بها
المقاتلون الاسلاميون مواقعهم في وسط
وشمال مالي فانهم وفق كثير من المحللين
اكثر قوه مما كان متوقعا وافضل تسليحا
وتدريبا والاكثر خطوره انهم يتحركون في
صحراء صديقه بمساحه شاسعه لا يقيمون فيها
وزنا لحكومات او
حدود لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من العاصمه
الفرنسيه برونو تتخ تتخ الباحث الاكاديمي
والخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه
في باريس ومن وكشط المحلل السياسي حسين
ومدو حسين ومدو
بحكم القرب من يعني المكان الذي يشهد
الحدث وهو مالي وبحكم اطلاع الموريتانيه
اكثر على المزاج الثقافي والشعبي وايضا
التدخلات هناك هل تعتقد بان تنظيم القاعده
س بامكانه ان يوحد صفوف الاسلاميين ويعلن
اماره ام ان هناك تحديات كبرى تعترض سبيله
في في تحقيق هذا
الهدف شكرا اعتقد بان تنظيم القاعده يواجه
تحديات كبيره ولكن بعودته شمالا يكون قد
عاد الى التصالح مع ذاته ومع طبيعته سواء
في طبيعه حرب العصابات ونزعتها اللا تماثل
او ال نمطيه التي تجعله اقدر على الضرب
واقدر على تلقي مختلف الضربات وسواء ايضا
باقترابه ايضا من الارضيه التي يمكن ان
تصلح لهذه العمليات حرب العصابات
والجماعات المسلحه بصفه عامه لذلك التوجه
جنوبا كان قد اعفى تنظيم القاعده ورفقائه
سواء في انصار الدين او سواء في حركه
التوحيد والجهاد من احدى اهم الخاصيات
التي ترتبط بعمل العصابات عموما وهي طبعا
اللا تماثل واللا نمطيه لهذه الحرب وطبيعه
الغطاء والارضيه التي تعمل عليها هذه
العصابات بعدما توجهت جنوبا وباتت مكشوفه
للغطاء الفرنسي والقوات المتحالفه معه
اعتقد بانه سيكون ثمه شهد مضاعف من طرف
القوات الفرنسيه وحلفاءها الماليين ايضا
والافارقه من اجل العمل على جبهتين الجبهه
الاولى هي محاوله تحييد ما امكن من
العناصر وهو ما شهدناه سابقا بفعل
الانشقاقات التي طالت القاعده سواء باعلان
حركه الزواد الاسلاميه او غيرها من
الفرقاء الذين التحقوا واعربوا عن امكانيه
التحاقهم بصف الدوله الماليه وحلفائها
الفرنسيين والعمل الثاني على تدمير كل
المراكز والخلفيات والقواعد الارضيه
الموجوده في تومبكتو وفي جاوا وغا وانا
على يقين بانه تقريبا من هنا لشهرين
ستستعيد مالي عمليا كل هذه المدن الثلاث
ولكن حرب العصابات تبدا عاده بنهايه
العمليات ولا تبتدع بها السيد تخ ضيفنا
يقول بان لن يكون صعبا على فرنسا وحلفائها
والحكومه الماليه ان تستعيد السيطره على
تلك المدن في الشمال المدن المهمه
الرئيسيه ولكنها ستدخل في صراع طويل ستدخل
ستجد نفسها مستدرج الى حرب عصابات ستنه
كها الى اي حد فرنسا كانت تتحسب وتستعيد
لمثل هذا
السيناريو
اعتقد ان فرنسا كانت مستعده تماما لهذا
النوع من السيناريوهات وخبره فرنسا طويله
على مستوى هذه العمليات العسكريه السريعه
مع اعداء يستخدمون تقنيات حرب العصابات و
حرب الشوارع كان ذلك في افريقيا او في
اسيا او حتى في افغانستان وغيرها من بلدان
العالم اعتقد ان فرنسا كانت مستعده
ومراقبه تماما لهذا النوع من التهديدات
ولا سما ان يحاول الاعداء اي تنظيم
القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي او
التوحيد والجهاد او انصار الدين اذا ان
يوحدوا صفوفهم ولكن ما يفاجئني اليوم هو
اننا امام حرب اعلام بشكل اساسي حرب
معلومات بمعنى ان الاعداء او منظمات
الاسلاميه تضعف قوتها في الوقت عينه نرى
انشقاقات في صلب انصار الدين وظهور حركات
او ربما توجهات مختلفه داخله نرى كذلك
المطار ازمه المطار فيو وكيف تمكنت القوات
الفرنسيه والماليه ان تضع يدها عليه اذا
انا وفقكم الراي اعتقد ان وضع اليد على
المدن الثلاثه في الشمال حتى تومبوكتو سوف
تكون بشكل سريع ربما في بعد بضعه اسابيع
لكن فرنسا وبحسب معلوماتي لا تنوي ان تذهب
هي
بقواتها لكي تستولي مره اخرى على منطقه
الاز باكملها او على مالي باكمله ليس هذا
هو الموضوع المطروح اما السؤال الفعلي فهو
بكل بساطه حمايه الشعب المالي في المدن
الكبيره هذا هو الهدف من العمليه لكن
فرنسا التي يعني اعلنت هذه الحرب
ودخلت رفقه حلفائها الافارقه ستكون قد قد
تكون في وقت ما مطره بالدفع بقواتها
البريه يقول البعض بحكم انها لم تلقى ذلك
الدعم الذي كانت تنشده من قبل من قبل دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى من الدول الغربيه
العظمى الاخرى كالولايات المتحده واكتفت
بالدعم لوجيستي
فقط في الواقع كانت فرنسا تنتظر دعما
لوجستيا اكبر من ذلك من قبل حلفائها
الاوروبيين والامريكيين لكن فرنسا لم تطلب
في اي من الاوقات دعما مثلا عسكريا او في
البر وفي الميدان من قبل حلفائها فرنسا
ليست بحاجه لكي تتواجد ق
الارض ل القوات هي القوات الافريقيه التي
سوف تقوم بذلك وفاجئني هذا الموضوع فعلا
بما ان الكتائب والقوات الافريقيه يجب ان
تزداد قدراتها حتى شهر سبتمبر ايلول وجدنا
في الواقع ايقاعا تسريع وزياده في حجم
العمليه الفرنسيه وهذا ما جعل القوات
الافريقيه تتضمن اليوم ملايين او الاف
عفوا الجنود اذا فرن سوف تشارك ربما في
الصفوف الخلفيه اذا ما جاز التعبير حين
تبدا القوات
الافريقيه بالعمل ميدانيا هذا الى جانب
القوات الماليه طبعا وهذه القوات
الافريقيه سوف تكون قادره بمفردها بتطبيق
قرار مجلس الامن سيد حسين ومدو الا يثير
ذلك الاستغراب ان فرنسا وهي تدخل او تقود
هذه الحمله تريد ان تدفع بالفارق في ان
يكونوا في الصفوف الاماميه وهي تعلم ان
هذا الصراع قد يطول رغم انها قد تستعيد
المدن الرئيسيه لكن الصراع مرشح لان يكون
طويلا جدا وهي غير مستعده بالزج بقوتها
ماذا تقرا انت في مثل
هذه الابعاد خاصه على الصعيد الاستراتيجي
وعلى الصعيد
المصالح اعتقد بانه استقراء الاوضاع في
فرنسا واستقراء طريقه التعاطي مع الازمه
الماليه بصفه عامه يبين بان اقدام
الجماعات المسلحه في مالي على عمليه
التوجه جنوبا كانت خطوه قد اربكت
الفرنسيين لذلك جاءت مبرراتهم للتدخل
متدرجه في الاول لحمايه بماكو ولاحقا بعد
اعلان هولند من الامارات باعاده بلوره
وصياغه مسوغات التدخل هذه وبنائها على
شرعيه قانونيه ولاحقا محاوله التفرد على
الاقل الفرنسي ودخولها دون استكمال
الاجراءات اللوجستيه والاجراءات القانونيه
وتولد عن ذلك درجه من الارباك جعلت حتى
الجيوش الافريقيه التي كانت مؤهله لان
تقدم الى الارضيه س قبل جعلتها متثاقلا
حتى من ناحيه وجود الاراده السياسيه
الكافيه للوصول الى هناك وهي تتقاطر على
هذه المنطقه بوحدات وباعداد قليله نسبيا
باستثناء التشاد الذي سيكون للدوري
الفرنسي دور كبير في الدفع بهذا الحجم
الكبير من جنودها حدود 2000 تقريبا الى
هذه المنطقه ولذلك فرنسا دفعت ضريبه كبيره
في محاوله التفرد بعمليه التدخل في مالي
اولا ومحاوله استكمال باقي الاجراءات سواء
من طرف الحلفاء في اوروبا او في افريقيا
كانت حريصه سابقا على ان لا تدخل الى
الميدان وانما ان تكتفي فقط بتسهيل انتشار
القوات الافريقيه ويبدو مع تثاقل هذه
القوات الافريقيه سيما مع المعوقات
والنواقص المرتبطه بالبعد المالي ودعوه
الامم المتحده الى محاوله اشراكها في
تمويل الحرب وهو ما يبدو انان كيمون قد
ابدا تمنعه منه اعتقد بان فرنسا في هذه
الحاله ستواجه صعوبات وتحديات كبيره ليس
على مستوى التعاطي مع الافارقه وانما حتى
على مستوى بدايه الانشقاق على ما يعرف
بالخطاب الاجماعي الذي اصطحبه هولاند
عشريه اطلاق الحمله في مالي بات ثمه
انشقاق على مستوى النخبه السياسيه ولما
يصل بعد الى حدود الراي العام الفرنسي
ولكن مع التجذر اكثر في زمن س وطول امد
الحرب سنكون امام درجه من الانشقاقات
الداخليه في فرنسا والتي ستم لي بعض من
الاكراهات على ضروره استعجال الخروج من
هذه المرحله والدخول في مرحله نهائيه سيد
ت خ اذا كانت فرنسا تعلم جيدا ان الحرب قد
تطول بحكم ان حرب العصابات تقوم على
التفجيرات وعمليه اختطاف والكمائن وغيرها
وستعتمد على القوات الافريقيه كما تقول
التي ستكون في الصفوف الاماميه هل ونحن
نعلم ان هذه القوات ليست لديها الخبره
وتجربه بما يكفي بمقار جماعات اسلاميه
مسلحه قد خبرت مثل هذه الحروب الا يدفع
ذلك الى يعني اعطاء مصداقيه لكثير من
الشكوك حول نوايا فرنسا من ه من خوض هذه
الحرب
اود ان اسلط ضوء على نقطه محدده ان القوات
الفرنسيه موجوده فعليا في الميدان وثمه
قوات خاصه من الفرنسيين وكذلك تجمعات
وتحركات تكتيكيه للفرنسيين في الميدان الا
ان فرنسا ولاسباب سياسيه ايضا تعرفون طبعا
ان هذا الموضوع يجب ان يتو الا فارقه
بانفسهم اذا لا ترغب فرنسا بان تكون
الم لكنها ليست حرب عف عذرا سيد تخ سيد
تخي عذرا انها ليست حرب الافارقه الافارقه
جرتهم فرنسا بحكم ولاء هذه الانظمه
لباريس نكن واضحين هذه العمليه سمحت بها
منظمه الامم المتحده وهذه العمليه طالبتها
الدوله الماليه بحد ذاتها وهذه عمليه ايضا
تدعمها بلدان افريقيا وغرب افريقيا
بالتحديد بشكل واسع ولا شك ان بدء العمليه
الفرنسيه قبل 15 يوما سرعت من ايقاع
العمليه العسكريه لكن اذا ما راينا اذا ما
نظرنا في عدد القوات الافريقيه التي تصل
والتي تصل بشكل سريع نسبيا هذا يعني انها
توافق على العمليه الفرنسيه واود ايضا ان
اشير النقطه التاليه اذا ما نظرنا الى
القدرات قدرات الافريقيه الجيش التشادي
تحديدا يتمتع بخبره واسعه على مستوى هذا
النوع من الصرعات في منطقه الصحراء وبشكل
خاص في مناطق نعرف ان جغرافيتها متشابهه
جدا وهي مشابهه لشمال مالي بالتحديد اذا
سوف تسرع اوروبا ايقاعها ايضا ايقاع
مساعدتها ودعمها وتدريبها
للجنود وتبدا هذه العمليه بعد 15 يوما اذا
نامل بشكل بكل عام ان تتمكن فرنسا
بمساعده الجيش المالي من وقف تقدم القوات
الجهاديه وهذا امر سجلناه وحص وان تتابع
ايضا باضعاف هذه المنظمات الاسلاميه وبعد
ذلك ان تنقل اذا ما جز التعبير الشعله الى
القوات الافريقيه لكي تتمكن من حمايه
المدن الكبرى ولكن ايضا اكبر جزء ممكن من
شمال مالي مع العلم طبعا
ان ذك قد يكون من المستحيل اي ان يتم
السيطره تماما على شمال مالي باكمله على
كل حال سنمضي قدما في قراءه ابعاد هذه
التهديدات التي اطلقها تنظيم القاعده في
بلاد المغرب الاسلامي وايضا ابعاد هذا
الصراع ولكن بعد هذا الفاصل وهذا ما
سنناقشه بعد فاصل قصير مشاه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الكرام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تتناول تهديدات تنظيم القاعده في بلاد
المغرب الاسلامي بشان حرب عصابات ضد
القوات الماليه وحلفائها الفرنسين
الافارقه ضيفنا من واشوط حسين ود مدو حسين
يعني الى اي حد قد تجد هذه الجماعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه التي يعني اعلنت عن هذا
التهديد وعن يتها اعلان اماره اسلاميه الى
اي حد ستجد نفسها مضطره لاعاده النظر في
تحالفاتها وايضا حساباتها بشان علاقتها مع
بض القوه الاقليميه في داخل
مالي شكرا جزيلا اعتقد بانه لحد الان
التحالف الفرنسي المالي ومن ورائه القوات
الافريقيه التي ستلتحق لاحقا كان قد وجه
ضربات قويه على الاقل للمراكز الكبيره
التي كانت تشكل مركزا لتواجد هذه لوجود
هذه المجموعات الاسلاميه بصفه عامه ولكن
كما قلت واعود دائما لاكر بان هذه انه
يمنح لهذه القوات مزيدا من الفرص للتصالح
مع ذاتها التخطيطيه
اصلا في عودتها الى حرب العصابات بصفه
عامه وكما تلاحظون فان اولى الضربات نعم
عذر المقاطعه ولكن الا يمكن ان تكون
المساله عكسيه بحكم ان بعض هذه الحركات قد
تكون انتهازيه وقد تستغل فرنسا وحلفاؤها
والحكومه الماليه ذلك وتضرب هذه الحركات
ببعضها
بعضا
ربما بتلوح ب بعض المصالح لهذه
الجماعات بدانا نشاهد جزء من ذلك على على
الاقل من خلال العديد من الانشقاقات التي
حدثت سواء على مستوى المجموعات او على
مستوى الافراد بالنسبه لحركه تحرير ازواد
وغيرها ولكن سنلاحظ اكثر بان الحرب
انطلاقا من بعدها الاقليمي ايضا وبان
اعلانها كان في مالي واولى الرصاصات طالت
اساسا الجزائر سنجد بان دول الميدان سيكون
لها دور اكبر في محاوله تحييد بعض
المجموعات من ولائها للقاعده خصوصا
ومحاوله عزل المجموعات المسلحه بصفه عامه
عن باقي التنظيمات المحليه التي لها
مطالبها ومظالم الخاصه والتي يبدو ان
الحرب على الجماعات المسلحه كانت قد اغفلت
هذا الجانب وجعلت الجميع في عباءه واحده
لذلك انا من الذين يعتقدون بان العمل
سيكون على جبهتين الجبهه الاولى هي عمليه
تقليم غافر الجماعات المسلحه عبر توجيه
هذه الضربات وثانيا تحييد مختلف الفرقاء
المحليين سيما في انصار الدين الاكثر
تجذراً ض من ما يعرف بالدعاء والركائز
الاساسيه التي تستند عليها الجماعات
الاسلاميه في مواجهتها وضمنا الى ذلك ايضا
استعاده دوله مالي لسيادتها الوطنيه
وتلبيه المطالب وتلبيه عديد المغالي
يواجهها اقليم ازواد بصفه عامه من غبن ومن
قهر طيله عقود من الزمن سيد تخي احد قاده
الحركه الوطنيه تحرير ازواد قال بان
الحركه لديها من الرجال
والخبره ما مكنها من لعبي دور مهم في
الحرب على الارهاب في او القضاء على
الارهاب في الزوات هل يمكن ربما ان نشهد
السيناريو ممثل ما عرفه العراق على شاكله
مجالس الصحوه كما كان ذلك الامر في في
الانبار
ج لا اعرف اذا ما كان السيناريو العراقي
الذي تشيرون اليه قد ينطبق او يمكن ان
ينقل تماما بحذافيره في شمال مالي ولكن
انا اوافقك الراي في التحليل الذي سمعناه
للتو نعم ان هذا
التنظيم موجود وجاهز للتعامل وتعاوني مع
القوات الافريقيه وايضا مع الحكومه
الماليه ومع الفرنسيين اعتقد انه من
الممكن تماما ان نجد هذا النوع من
السيناريو ومن خلال هذا التعاون بالذات
يمكن اذا ان يتم فصل
الموت المختلفه للاعداء لمنظمات المسلحه
لكن المشكله تكمن في مكان اخر ايضا بين
العاصمه بامك والدوله الماليه وبين هذا
التنظيم لتحرير اذا هذه العلاقات ليست
دائما وديه اذا ما جزت تعبير الان بالنسبه
للتنظيم القاعده في دول او في بلدان
المغرب الاسلامي الاكم تعتبر فرنسا انه ان
الوقت قد حان لها لكي تدمر الى اكبر قدر
ممكن هذا التنظيم تنظيم القاعده الجهادي
هذا التنظيم بعيني الذي صرح منذ سنوات
وسنوات ان فرنسا انما هي العدو هذا
التنظيم ايضا والذي حاول مرارا وتكرارا
بالقيام باعتداءات داخل فرنسا هذا ما
تقوله الحكومه الفرنسيه على الاقل اذا
اعتقد ان اراده فرنسا موجوده وهي ضرب
تنظيم القاعده في بلدان المغرب الاسلامي
الاكي من غيرها من المنظمات طيب هذه
المواجهه سيد الحسين ومد الان بين فرنسا
وهذه الجماعات الاسلاميه المسلحه وتناقضات
الان القائمه بين
الحركات التي تنشط على ض في على شمال مالي
في اقليم الزواد بالتحديد الى اي حد قد
يؤثر على مصير مالي وعلى دول الجوار
تحديدا وبكل تاكيد كل بلدان المنطقه خصوصا
دول الميدان كانت قد اكتوت بنار هذه
الجماعات المسلحه وعمليه مقاومتها تصادف
هذا هو لدا مختلف كل هذه الانظمه سيما
النظامين الجزائري والنظام الموريتاني
وهما من اكتوى بنار الارهاب سواء في
السنوات الماضيه او سواء الجماعات المسلحه
مؤخرا ايضا ما تمايز فقط او ما ميز هذين
النظامين اساسا هو ان دوله مالي تحت قياده
ف مانيتو ارادت ان تتعايش الى جانب هذه
هذه الحركات ولم تش ان تدفع الضريبه ولا
ان ت اثر على الاقل بمفهوم المواجهه مع
هذه الجماعات لذلك كانت طبيعه الضريبه
ستدفعها على البعد الاستراتيجي في فقدان
سيادتها الوطنيه وفي تشرم بلدها وفي
انفجار مختلف المطالب غير الشرعيه بما
فيها الوصول الى انقسام وتقسيم وتوزيع هذه
الدوله واعتقد بان هذه الم طيب اعتقد بان
هذه اعتقد بان هذه المواجهه التي تحدث
الان حتى ولو تم ابتسار بطريقه اظهرت بان
التدخل الفرنسيه لم يكن مبررا ولما يستكمل
بعد الاجراءات القانونيه واللوجستيه الا
انه من مصلحه الانظمه سواء في موريتانيا
او سواء في الجزائر في وضع حد لعمليات
الانفجار التي تشهد التفجيرات التي تشهدها
دائما وتنفذها هذه الجماعات المسلحه والتي
حولت المنطقه بفعل غياب الراعي الدائم
والوصي الدائم الى نوع يزدهر فيه ما يعرف
بتجاره الاقتصاد اقتصاد الجريمه سواء تعلق
الامر باختطاف او سواء تعلق الامر بغير
ذلك
و تامل مختلف هذه البلدان ان تستعيد اصحاب
المغالي ظالمهم في منطقه ازواد خصوصا وان
تستعيد مالي وحدتها واكيد بانه لا يمكن
التعويل في هذه الحاله فقط على الجيوش
الافريقيه نظرا لنقص القدره الكبير على
المستوى اللوجستي وعلى المستوى المالي وان
فرنسا ان ارادت ان تتكفل ايضا بمجرد
عمليات ضرب منتهيه وتنتهي فورا فان ذلك لن
ياتي الى حل القضيه وانما سي فقط الى دعني
افصح المجال خي في الاخير يعني كسؤال اخير
سخي فرنسا حينما تشن هذه الحرب الان في
مالي يعني تجازف باستقرار وامن دول مجاوره
لمالي وهذه الدول لا يبدو انها متحمسه لما
يجري كيف يمكن لفرنسا تقدم ضمانات لهذه
الدول بانها لن تدفع فاتوره ما تقدم عليه
فرنسا
الان لابد هنا من التمييز بين هذه البلدان
المجاوره معظم البلدان المجاوره في الجنوب
وكذلك بلدان الاكواس تدعم بشكل تام وحتى
عسكريا المقاطعه سخ نحدد الجزائر
وموريتانيا تحديدا
الجزائر تماما تماما كنت اود الوصول الى
الجزائر تحديدا ويمكن القول هنا انه مثلا
قبل اسبوعين اثنين كانت الجزائر متحفظه
فيما يتعلق بهذه العمليه العسكريه ولكن
نعرف الان وبشكل علني وصريح ان الجزائر
سمحت للطائرات الفرنسيه بعبور مجالها
الجوي واعتقد ان الجزائر قد فهمت بمفردها
بان تطور وجود هذا هذه الارض وهذا الملجا
وهذه الحركه التجاريه المخيفه عند حدودها
ليست عمليه سهله او قد تضرب في نهايه
المطاف امنها وسلامها اذا ما رايناه ايضا
في الجزائر من عمليه خطف الرهائن قبل ع
ايام تظهر ايضا بما لا يقبل الشك ان
الجزائر تود وجود سياسه واضحه فيما تتعرض
مصالحها للخطر شكرا لك سيد بونو ت الخبيره
في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه والباحث
الاكاديمي من باريس ونشكر ضيفنا من وكشط
المحلل السياسي حسين ومدو وشكرا لمتابعتكم
مشاهدينا الكرام والى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
c